How might drinking alkaline water affect your daily, your body's hydration?
Now I'm going to phrase this question two ways because I'm assuming this person is asking
will drinking alkaline water affect your hydration?
Knowing that my philosophy of drinking alkaline water is not a good idea.
So let's start with that just so everybody who made out of asked this question understands that.
I don't think it's a good idea to drink alkalized water. The reason is that your stomach pH
has to remain at a very low level or very acidic pH and if your stomach gets too alkaline
all sorts of bad things will happen and I have several blog posts out of that.
The need for HCL production by your stomach cells and the problem with your stomach cells not
being able to produce HCL. Very, very common. Maybe the most common thing that causes ill help.
We always talk about leaky gut issues and inflammation in the gut. We can all start with a decreased
ability to produce HCL and what are you doing when you take PPI's or you're taking even
tons or something like that. These medications that block HCL production, they can give you temporary
relief from like an acidic burp up of reflux acid but always no symptoms of acidic coming up your
esophagus and affecting your esophagus and you've tasted acid in your model to this reflux issues
are all from ironically a decreased HCL production. You're not getting enough HCL production.
It's not breaking down the bolus who did your stomach and then what is there is the pushed up
through the esophagus and then you're burping that up. So ironically you need more HCL when you get
reflux and people are going in there taking tons, roll aids, going to get PPI's which is the
you're just going to you're setting yourself up for very, very serious diseases and when you do that.
So have several blog posts of that but does drinking alkaline water affect bodies hydration?
No. So if you're drinking alkaline water you know it will be acidified by if you have decent
HCL in your stomach so there's no benefit of drinking alkaline water all the alkaline water
companies that are pushing the alkaline water because it alkalizes your body. This is completely
wrong physiology so it's it doesn't stay alkaline once it gets into your small intestine by that time
it's not alkaline it's just water. So if they're alkalizing it with using minerals to alkalize it or
something like that then you're maybe absorbing those minerals typically they're not going to use good
quality minerals to alkalize it anyhow so it can be even more harmful if they're using poor quality
minerals then you are actually blocking absorption sites for good quality minerals. So
I have several videos on you know good supplements, bad supplements. So poor quality minerals
and consumption of poor quality minerals typically in supplementation poor quality supplements
or like grains and things that are have fortified minerals. So typically really poor quality minerals
that could actually block absorption sites for if you're eating good food with good quality minerals.
So there's a lot of things why you shouldn't drink alkaline water but is it affected your body's hydration?
No as far as hydrating goes it's probably the exact same if you're drinking regular water. So whether
you're acidifying your water by adding let's say lemon juice to it or apple cider vinegar to it or
you're alkalizing water by you to prescribe alkalized water drink or getting one of those alkalizing water
machines. It's not affecting your hydration it's just it's still going to be absorbed with water.
So it's still it's good for hydration this is bad for your gut as far as alkalizing water close.